>>> RUSSIAN SOLDIERS CRYING AS
THEY RECOUNT PHONE CALLS WITH
THEIR FAMILI, DESCRIBING
PUTIN'S INVASION AND SHELLING OF
CITIES CRIMES ON THE UKRANIAN
PEOPLE.
SAYING THEY WERE DECEIVED BY
RUSSIA'S MILITARY OPERATION, AND
SAYING PUTIN IS TRYING TO SEIZE
THE WORLD OF ALL HE IS INVADING.
WE TALKED TO SEBASTIAN SHUKLA IN
A MIRACULOUS CONVERSATION,
SAYING, QUOTE, I KNOW IN MY UNIT
THEY ARE TOTALLY AGAINST IT.
SEBASTIAN SHUKLA IS UP FRONT,
AND HE'S BEEN COVERING THE WAR
IN UKRAINE SINCE THE INVASION.
I KNOW YOU'VE SPENT AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE
COUNTRY, IN THE DONBAS.
SEB, YOU HAVE THIS CHANCE TO
MEET WITH THESE PEOPLE UP CLOSE.
THEY WERE UPSET WITH THE
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
ONE SOLDIER TOLD YOU, IT WAS A
HORRIFYING FACT NOT JUST BECAUSE
IT WAS A CRIME.
IT'S VANDALISM.
YOU CAN'T FORGIVE SUCH THINGS.
TO BOMB A MATERNITY WARD?
THE SOLDIER, OF COURSE, WAS
REFERRING TO THAT MARIUPOL
MATERNITY WARD BOMBING WHICH
KILLED A WOMAN AND HER UNBORN
CHILD.
TELL ME A LITTLE ABOUT THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> I WAS ABLE TO SPEAK ONE TO
ONE AFTER A PRESS CONFERENCE ON
FRIDAY IN KYIV, AND I CAN SAY
HONESTLY THAT THEY SOUNDED
REMORSEFUL TO ME.
THEY SOUNDED REGRETFUL FOR WHAT
HAPPENED.
I WANT TO START SAYING INITIALLY
THAT WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE
DOING HERE IS INCREDIBLY
CONTROVERSIAL.
THEY ARE VIOLATING ONE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LAWS, WHICH IS ON
HUMAN RIGHTS, THE GENEVA
CONVENTION WHICH TALKS ABOUT NOT
MAKING PRISONERS OF WAR ITEMS OF
PUBLIC DEBATE, AND THAT IS
CLEARLY WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE,
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE I SPOKE TO,
BUT ALL THE OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
PARADED ON UKRANIAN TELEVISION,
TOO.
I WANT TO READ YOU SOME OF THE
QUOTES THAT THEY TOLD US.
AND IT SAYS, WE DON'T SEE ANY
NAZIS OR FASCISTS.
I THINK IT WAS INVENTED AS A
PRETEXT, IT'S SOMETHING THE
WORLD CANNOT UNDERSTAND, BUT
PUTIN AND HIS CIRCLE NEED THIS
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THEIR OWN
OBJECTIVES.
BUT NOW CITIES WITH PEACEFUL
CIVILIANS ARE BEING DESTROYED.
EVEN I DON'T KNOW WHAT CAN
JUSTIFY THE TEARS OF A CHILD, OR
EVEN WORSE, THE DEATHS OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE AND CHILDREN.
I THINK IT'S ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
JUST FROM THAT ONE QUOTE THAT
THIS IS NOT A WAR THAT THEIR
HEARTS ARE INVESTED IN, AND IT
SEEMS VERY, VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
IS PRESIDENT PUTIN'S WAR, NOT
THEIRS.
>> I MEAN, IT IS PRETTY
STUNNING, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU THINK OF THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE OF ONE OF THE LARGEST
MILITARIES ON THIS PLANET, IT
ALL RELIES ON SOLDIERS BEING
WHAT THEY'RE TOLD.
I KNOW -- EVEN TALKING TO THEM,
IT'S CONTROVERSIAL, AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE NOT SHOWING THEIR
FACES AND YOU'RE CHOOSING NOT TO
SHOW THE VIDEO.
THEY TELL YOU THIS TREATMENT HAS
BEEN ACCEPTABLE, THEY OFFERED US
FOOD AND DRINK, THEY OFFERED
MEDICAL TREATMENT.
DID THE SOLDIERS GIVE YOU ANY
IMPRESSION THAT THEY WERE
SPEAKING.
BUT I DIDN'T GHAET RECALL
OFFICERS IN THE ROOM.
THEY HAD AK-47s, AND THERE WAS
NOTHING TO SAY THAT IT WAS
SCRIPTED IN ANY WAY.
A LOT OF WHAT WAS SAID CAME FROM
WHO WOULD BE THE RANKING OFFICER
IN THE ROOM.
YOU KNOW, THEY SPOKE CANDIDLY
ABOUT WANTING TO BE ABLE TO GO
HOME AND WANTING TO BE ABLE TO
GO AND SEE THEIR FAMILIES BUT
ALSO THE UNCERTAINTY OF WHAT IS
GOING TO R.
OUR FATE IS IN THE ARMED FORCES
OFFED.
MANY -- THE BOMBS HAVE BEEN
UPDATED AND UPGRADED AND THEY
ARE DROPPED INDISCRIMINATELY SO
THAT WHEN THEY LAND, THE DAMAGE
IS EXTENSIVE, AND I THINK IT'S
VERY, VERY CLEAR THAT THE WORLD
IS JUDGING THEM NOW AND TH